okay now Wi-Fi
you guys know I'm really into name
somewhere they come from right I just
spent all this time talking about 8:00
or 2:15 Wi-Fi is one of the places where
the technology the technology industry
has really led us down it makes me very
sad okay
what does Wi-Fi stand for it stand for
well the wife stands for wireless that's
that's what's your heart what does the
five step for there does anyone know
five five five what not a bad idea any
any other suggestions five over okay
wireless firewall this is about very
communication between people yeah find
out while it's funny that wouldn't be a
bad idea
those are all much better suggestions
than what the real answer is which is
now hold on a second let me try to
explain this where this fatality and
then let me explain why it's such a bad
word what does fidelity mean fidelity
has to do the quality okay I could I
could go into the Latin feed a which
actually is the root word for faith
anyway there's a long story
it basically means quality okay yeah
like Wireless quality what is Wireless
quality and the answer is nothing is
completely meaningless but this is
abbreviation came from another
abbreviation which is very popular sort
of 80s and 90s namely high five from
wafer which JB hi-fi gets their name now
Chuck high five
since for high fidelity which actually
makes sense high quality it's actually
talking about stereos and sound quality
and you got lo-fi which is like that
terrible stuff which comes out or your
radio and it's not that sound good and
you got high five which is like surround
and it's really good quality CD called
the audio file of all right so high fine
makes sense and if someone looks like
well it's wireless what's a cool name
would you go with you know
Bluetooth head move it up there let's go
with Wi-Fi it rhymes
it's like the same
but different and and then it's stuck
because it's sort of it got picked up by
the media and it just people just went
with it
despite the fact it was okay so yeah I
don't like this name but that's that's
what it is okay now does anyone know
what's its real proper name just like
bluetooth has a popular name and it has
a real name
does anyone know the real name of Wi-Fi
I'll give you a clue it starts off the
same way as the name from Bluetooth
because it was decided by the same guys
I should play 802 because again it's
about wireless communication but it's
not 50 its 1111 okay and then after 11
what will happen is there's a series of
letters that comes after this right so
for instance one of the most recent ones
is 802 11 and there was 802 11 G and 802
11 ancients okay so let's go to it
I should police a bunch of guys 802 same
kind of it's still wireless
communication but 11 it's a different
standard because it has to do with
different powered radios and different
protocols that go over it right the end
or actually any of the letters stands
for revision because this technology has
changed a lot over the years because
people want to do more stuff on it they
want to transport more data through it
and the protocol keeps getting updated
and revised okay so when you see
different letters here you know
eventually we're get to see I don't know
what they gonna do after Zed you know
maybe they'll start doing Greek letters
that'll be fun but all it means is same
idea same Wi-Fi but more power more
range or bandwidth all those kinds of
things okay all right now um under 800
Jeremy you can kind of assume if this is
802 11 and this is 802 15 there's all
these other ones in between here right
there are a lot they're not as common
which is not why I'm not going to deal
with them but what I do want to quickly
mention is and if see you might have
heard this before not to be confused
with KFC stands for I knew
field communications okay so I'm gonna
get you guys to research that a bit
later how is it different it's the
communications technology that underpins
our you know all of the credit cards and
they have like payWave and pay pass or
whatever they're all called right so the
idea that there's a there's an NFC chip
built into a credit card that gets read
by something else okay and you don't
have to touch or you don't swipe your
actual car